diplo l eau amigo ça que tu leur compte
en fait moins de 50 kg on dit toujours
avec moi je m'en sert comme d'une
amulette très bien avec big flo et oli
c'est de l'art
samedi 13h big flo et oli débarque à la
ravine blanche
il leur reste un peu plus de huit heures
avant leur concert ce soir franck au
frigo
des chaussées vous les gars
il n'y a pas une minute à perdre à peine
arrivés les deux frères attaque les
balances répétition et réglages
techniques mais bien direct 2d les bêtes
et balance ça fait trois mois qu'on
n'est pas monté sur scène à bas prix
c'est chez vous à la réunion soit big
love you lie ont bien l'intention de
faire bouger des 10000 spectateurs des
francophones et deux ans après leur
dernier concert dans l'île
ils reviennent avec un nouveau titre
dans tout accouplé par le de la réunion
et l'océan ma chouchoute
production de couleur sur la photo puis
l'engueulade sur sierra 40 autos et
bienvenue chez moi tu viens d'une grande
ville ou d'un village c'est magnifique
et si je disais que cet or si quelques
organisateurs et bénévoles seulement ont
la chance d'être aux premières loges
[Musique]
c'est alors qu'olivier aux empreintes
notre smartphone pour filmer son frère
les balances ont duré un peu plus d'une
heure
rendez-vous maintenant avec les fans
[Applaudissements]
si mr tient compte et non de celtic a
fait beaucoup trop et maintenant
direction la conférence de presse devant
les journalistes et florian et olivier
évoque le succès qui est venu si vite
leurs trois premiers albums se sont
vendus à des centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires
ils viennent d'être sacrée artiste de
l'année aux victoires de la musique et
ils se disent parfois que les sba sarah
trop bien que là on arrive à un niveau
que moi je pensais atteindre un mois de
jubiler à 40 ans tu vois pensez que ça
va arriver est allé voir mes enfants ma
femme tu regardes en plus c'est un mec
après des cas après j'allais pouvoir
mourir tranquille et là ça arrive un peu
tôt
parce que deux ans
ce niveau là et en quoi il est
maintenant 15 heures et après une
nouvelle série de sel fille les deux
frères partent se reposer non ils
partent pour trois heures de réunion
avec leur équipe dans un hôtel du front
de mer
objectif préparer leur prochain concert
géant dans le stade de toulouse devant
plus de 30000 spectateurs
[Musique]
nous les retrouvons le soir à l'heure du
journal télévisé
il reste deux heures avant le concert
mais on entend déjà au loin la foule qui
les à clé
[Applaudissements]
répétition la promotion selphy réunion
de travail
florian et religieux n'ont pas arrêté un
instant depuis que nous les suivre à la
réunion mais là les amis beaucoup de
boulot mais c'est vrai que c'est des
grosses journées et c'est marrant tu le
dises parce que souvent les gens
peut-être réalise pas les miens c'est
vrai qu'en tout cas on n'est plus très
impliqué il ya beaucoup de points
positifs mais la vie d'artiste et
beaucoup de travail aussi c'est pas que
cela coulait douce et faire des concerts
de dix mille personnes qui vous
attendent
ouais vous imaginez ça va faire vous
allez chanter complet sur la réunion
j'espère qu'ils connaîtront ils
arrivaient l'imaginaire du oui j'espère
sinon ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas fait
notre job c'est d'aller sur une fiche de
volcans renversé mois et l'océan je suis
chaud la nuit
vous rappeler comment il est et ce
couple et la robella en fait on parlait
de la tournée en fait c'est un morceau
qui s'appelle bienvenue chez moi où on
parle de tous les endroits on est passé
en concert et
mais pas ne pas parler de cette sillage
de la réunion on a parlé de valeurs ona
rhône et on est lié à vie
avec les réunionnais n'était au
kabardock l'an 2015 le sakifo en 2016 a
eu des super raconte je partais la
réunion nous porte chance donc avec
l'expérience
les deux frères ont même appris comment
abréger une interview les avis étaient
brûlés vous avez suivi un peu toute la
journée venez de
vision vous avez suivi les balances
avait suivi la conférence de presse les
rencontres avec les gens et on doit vous
fais un bisou sera pas trop baisser la
réunion au cancer merci beaucoup
on sent tout le monde fut promise est qu
au dernier rang la réunion
alors est génial
à l'orée du pain
trois mois on a tous dit assez assez
c'était plein
et tu as
[Musique]
devant
pendant deux heures la foule va
reprendre en choeur les refrains des
deux jeunes toulousains et suda
avant de dire au revoir
florian et olivier aux fins de la foule
disparaissent dans la masse pour
réapparaître au dessus de la mêlée
plus tôt en deuxième vous demandez à vos
téléphones et vit des instants présents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le dernier album de big flo et oli
s'appelle la vie de rêve
les deux frères espère juste que ça va
durer
[Applaudissements]
mais
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]